É verdade que a teoria das placas amilo
no Alzheimer não existe foi um erro em
estudos? Olha que pergunta espinhosa que
eu recebi. Pessoal, imaginem só a
seguinte situação. Você passa décadas da
sua vida acreditando em algo, investido
tempo, energia e bilhões de dólares numa
teoria que parece fazer todo sentido do
mundo. Aí de repente alguém chega e fala
assim: "Ora, pera aí, tem algo muito
errado aqui". Foi exatamente isso que
aconteceu com a teoria das placas da
Miloides no Alzheimer em 2022. Mas calma
que a história não é bem assim tão
simples como parece.
Vamos voltar um pouquinho no tempo.
Desde 1906, 1906, quando o médico alemão
Alois Alzheimer descobriu umas placas
estranhas no cérebro de pacientes com
demência, a comunidade científica ficou
meio que obsecada com essas benditas
placas. Sabe aquela sensação quando você
encontra o culpado perfeito? Pois é,
todo mundo achou que tinha encontrado o
vilão da história. As placas amiloides
viraram o bode expiatório do Alzheimer.
Tipo assim: "Ah, encontramos placas no
cérebro, então é isso que causa doença."
E olha que não foi qualquer
investimentozinho, não. Só nos Estados
Unidos o governo federal gastou 1,6
bilhão de dólares em 2022 pesquisando
essas placas amiloids. É muita grana,
né? Quase metade de todo o dinheiro
destinado à pesquisa de Alzheimer foi
parar nessa teoria. Aí você deve estar
se perguntando, mas doutor, e qual que é
o problema? Então, bom, o negócio
começou a desandar quando um
neurologista chamado Mefield Strug, lá
da Universidade Verbçar
uns estudos e descobriu algo bombástico,
um artigo super importante, 2006,
publicado na prestigiosa revista Nature,
que identificava uma proteína específica
chamado A beta 56, como a grande vilã do
Alzheimer.
Esse estudo tinha imagens manipuladas.
Pensa no tamanho do pepino. Esse estudo
foi citado mais de 2300 vezes e
influenciou duas décadas de pesquisa. Em
junho de 2024, o artigo foi finalmente
retratado, ou seja, retirado de
circulação. Mas aqui que a coisa fica
interessante e é super importante vocês
entenderem isso. A fraude nesse estudo
específico não significa que toda a
teoria milod está errada. É como se você
descobrisse que um tijolo da sua casa
foi mal colocado. Isso não significa que
a casa inteira vai cair. A hipótese
Miloide ainda tem fundamentação
científica sólida, com milhares de
estudos independentes que mostram alguma
relação, alguma relação entre as placas
e a doença. O problema mesmo é aí que tá
o pulo do gato, é que a comunidade
científica ficou tão vidrada nessa
teoria que esqueceu de olhar o quadro, o
panorama geral. É aquilo, né? Quando
você tá com martelo na mão, tudo parece
prego. E tem uma coisa bem curiosa, nem
todo mundo que tem placas amiloides
envolve Alzheimer. E nem todo mundo que
tem Alzheimer tem uma quantidade absurda
de placas. Bem complicado, né? E olha
que coisa doida. Já tivemos alguns
medicamentos aprovados como aducanumab e
o lecanemab que até consegue limpar
essas placas do cérebro. Mas sabe qual é
o resultado? uma melhora bem
pequenininha, quase imperceptível na
cognição dos pacientes. Alguns estudos
mostram até que esses remédios podem
acelerar a atrofia cerebral. É como
limpar a fumaça sem apagar o incêndio,
entendeu? Agora mudando um pouquinho o
rumo da conversa, deixa eu te contar uma
coisa que pode dar uma esperança danada
para vocês. E quando todo mundo tava
brigando sobre essas questão das placas
amiloides, um neurocientista chamado
Draden passou mais de 30 anos estudando
o cérebro de um jeito diferente. Ele
desenvolveu o protocolo recode, que
significa reversão do declínio
cognitivo. E eu fiz essa formação e fui
o primeiro brasileiro a fazer e o
segundo América Latina. E não é que o
homem conseguiu documentar melhoras em
centenas de pacientes. A sacada do Dr.
Braden é genial e ao mesmo tempo óbvia.
Ele trata aos hamers como se fosse um
telhado com 36 buracos. Não adianta só
tapar um buraco se os outros 35
continuam entrando, deixando entrar a
chuva. Então ele identifica todos os
fatores que podem estar contribuindo pro
declínio cognitivo de cada paciente.
Pode ser desequilíbrio hormonal,
inflamação, deficiências nutricionais.
exposição a toxinas, problemas de sono,
estresse crônico, é um monte de coisa. E
sabe o que que é mais legal?
O protocolo é totalmente personalizado,
não é aquela história de receita de bolo
que serve para todo mundo. Cada paciente
faz uma bateria de exames, incluindo
testes bioquímicos e muitas vezes
genéticos, para identificar exatamente
quais são os seus buracos no telhado.
Depois monta-se um plano de tratamento
específico que pode incluir mudanças na
alimentação, suplementação, exercícios
físicos, técnica de gerenciamento de
estresse, melhora do sono e até mesmo
treinamento cognitivo.
Em 2022, Dr. Bradsen publicou o primeiro
ensaio clínico da história, onde em vez
de predeterminar um tratamento único
para Ozheimer, cada paciente foi
avaliado individualmente e tratado de
forma personalizada. E os resultados
foram impressionantes. Tem gente que
mantém melhora cognitiva mais de 5 anos
seguindo o protocolo. É claro que nem
todo mundo responde da mesma forma e
quanto mais cedo você começa, melhores
são os resultados. Mas olha, não vou
mentir para vocês, tem muita gente na
comunidade científica tradicional que
torce o nariz protocolo recod. Dizem que
falta evidência científica, que os
estudos são pequenos, que é tudo
anedótico e de fato a gente precisa de
mais pesquisas, estudos maiores, mais
tempo de acompanhamento. Mas pensa
comigo, se você, alguém que você ama, tá
enfrentando declínio incognitivo, você
vai esperar mais 20 anos por um remédio
milagroso ou vai tentar algo que já
mostrou resultados promissores e que no
mínimo vai melhorar toda a qualidade de
vida desse paciente? O que eu acho mais
bacana nessa abordagem da medicina
funcional é que ela não descarta
completamente a teoria amiloide. As
placas podem sim fazer parte do
problema, mas elas são apenas uma peça
do quebra-cabeça. E tem uma coisa que a
gente não pode esquecer. O cérebro é
plástico, ele tem capacidade de se
regenerar e criar novas conexões. Quando
você trabalha todos os aspectos,
nutrição, exercício, sono, controle de
estresse, estímulo cognitivo, você tá
dando pro seu cérebro as ferramentas que
ele precisa para se recuperar. Para
finalizar, eu quero deixar uma mensagem
de esperança para vocês. O Alzheimer não
precisa ser uma sentença de morte. Sim,
ainda temos muito que aprender, mas já
sabemos o suficiente para fazer
diferença na vida das pessoas. Se você
tem histórico familiar, não espere os
sintomas aparecerem. Comece já a fazer a
prevenção, cuidar do seu cérebro.
Alimente-se, exercite-se do direito,
controle o seu estresse, mantenha sua
mente ativa e suas conexões sociais
fortes. E se você ou alguém próximo já
está enfrentando declín cognitivo,
procure profissionais que trabalhem com
protocolo recode, com essa abordagem
integrativa. O futuro tratamento do
Alzheimer não está numa pílula mágica,
mas numa transformação completa do seu
estilo, do nosso estilo de vida. Isso,
meus amigos, tá ao alcance de todos nós.